the improved indigenous chicken is also
known as an improved keni Chicken in
Kenya it is a breed made by crossing
different local or kenyi chickens from
Kenya the result is a bird that matures
faster and is high producing compared to
the traditional kyi bird kyi chickens
are the most common type of poultry
among small holders in Kenya this is
because they are one easy to get two
easy to maintain three high in
demand what will improved Ki chicken
provide one meat for consumption two
eggs three money from selling the
chickens or eggs Ki chicken is an easy
source of income for women and youth in
rural areas as one can start with just a
few chickens and add more slowly
welcome to the world of improved kenyi
chicken a game changer for small holder
farmers in Kenya these birds grow faster
produce more eggs and thrive on less
feed in this video we'll show you how to
raise these chickens for maximum profit
from choosing the right breed to
building the perfect Coupe don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more
farming tips and insights hit the like
button and sh share this video to
support our community of farmers let's
unlock the secrets of successful kyi
chicken farming
together why keep improved Ki chicken
one they need less feed than layers and
brers two they eat kitchen waste and
leftovers three chicken meat and eggs
are good sources of protein especially
for children and nursing mothers four
they are a good source of income five
they are easily available in rural areas
and near Urban centers at affordable
prices in Kenya there are different
breeds of improved kyi Birds here are
five best breeds to choose from first Ki
improved this breed was developed by the
Kenya Agricultural and livestock
research organization k a l o it will
grow fast to a weight of 1.5 kg in 5
months they will lay around 200 to 270
eggs per
year two the Kura bird with this breed
you easily convert the kitchen and farm
waste into meat and eggs they are a fast
growing breed they lay around 150 eggs
per
year third rainbow rooster this is a
fast growing multicolored bird
it was bred by a research and breeding
Farm in India they have to be fed
commercial layer feeds to lay 160 to 180
eggs per
year four kenro chicken they have red
feathers they grow fast if kept for meat
they can grow to a weight of 1.5 kgs in
just 3 months if kept for eggs they will
start laying in just 6 months
they lay around 200 eggs per
year sinkam Sasso this are multicolored
Birds which grow slowly they will lay
around 150 to 200 eggs with good
management mostly raised for meat and is
left free to eat grass worms and insects
with little
supplementation there are three main
ways of keeping improved kenyi chickens
one free and semi- free range free range
is where the chickens are left free to
eat worms insects grasses and leaves
around the farm they are then sheltered
at night semi-free range is where birds
are put in an enclosed place for some
time and given food they are then
allowed to roam outside to eat worms
insects grasses and leaves around the
farm this is my personal favorite so you
know
second fold unit system this is also
known as a chicken tractor birds are
kept in a small movable house made out
of wire mesh big enough for the chickens
to move around this house is moved from
one spot to another every day this
system is best suited to small scale
operations and chicken
vendors third small scale confined
system this is also known
as the deep litter system the chicken
house is made of concrete floors but
covered with litter wood shavings that
is to make Birds feel comfortable the
house is big to allow the chickens to
move freely food and water are provided
inside the house it is expensive but the
best for commercial chicken
farming chicken equipment both Drinkers
and feeders should always be kept clean
and wellmaintained
this will prevent cases of diseases in
your chicken these are the equipments
required to raise 100 chicks
comfortably
feeders one feeder for every 50-day old
chicks cleaned and disinfected all with
fresh starter
feed drinkers one Drinker for every
50-day old chicks cleaned and
disinfected regularly and with fresh
water always use 6 l or 10 L drink of
what are features of a good Drinker has
a Twist lock system and a hanger or
carry handle easy to fill easy to clean
drinkers come in different sizes 1 lit 6
L and 10 L choose as it
fits litter use wood shavings or rice
husks not sawdust as chicks can choke
spread evenly to a depth of 5 to 10 cm
the litter should be soft and dry
heat
Source ensure that you have a source of
heat like a brooda Joo and it is working
well maintain a good temperature for
your
birds light the idea is to provide 23
hours of light for the first seven days
as this dramatically improves chick
development brooder guards round plywood
is used to make the brooding area 1.5 m
squ per 50 ch
the area is cleaned disinfected and with
well spread fresh litter cover this area
with paper and remove after 3 days
looking to dive even deeper get our full
expert guide packed with all the details
it's a clucking great deal WhatsApp us
at the number in the description and
secure your copy
today saucing for chicks here are three
ways to get good and healthy chicks
chicks one hatching own chicks mother
hen sits on eggs for 21 days to keep
them warm until they hatch this is a
natural process she can sit and incubate
her own eggs or those of another hen
it's the simplest way of hatching a
small number of eggs I prefer giving one
hen only eight eggs to hatch you have
almost 100% hatch rate
two artificial brooding incubating
machines are used to hatch eggs into
chicks it's mostly used by farmers who
are in the business of selling day old
chicks or keeping many birds it hatches
many eggs at
once three buying day old chicks from
hatcheries you can buy day old chicks
from hatcheries directly and start
brooding the chickens on your farm
identify registered hatcheries or chick
nurseries to buy day old chicks select
hatcheries that vaccinate chicks against
marik's
disease brooding is a period right after
the chicks have hatched and special care
and attention is needed to support their
health and survival because hatch chicks
can't control their own body temperature
in the first weeks you need to provide
extra heat otherwise chicks will be too
cold and May may not eat well drink
enough or may even
die one traditional brooding here
brooding is done by the mother chicken
she covers the young ones with her wings
to keep them
warm two artificial brooding when there
is no mother hen to look after her
chicks you need to set up an artificial
brooder during the first 2 to 3 weeks
chicks need to be kept in a brooder as
they cannot control their own body
temperature yet you need to give them
special care to support their health and
survival artificial heat helps keep
chicks stay warm until the feathers grow
heat can be provided by using a brooding
go gas or
electricity remember without the extra
warmth chicks can easily feel cold and
may not eat or drink enough and their
digestive organs may not develop
properly
improved kyi chickens need feed that
contains the following one energy second
protein third vitamins four minerals
five
water feed requirement is dependent on
the age and status of the birds chicks
Growers layers meat birds and broody
hens there are different types of
chicken feed for the different age
categories as I am about to discuss
chicks below the age of 8 weeks feed
them with chick Mash as it provides high
protein quantities chicks between the
age of 8 and 18 weeks feed them with
Growers Mash to provide a balanced diet
so that the chicks can gain weight fast
when the chicks start laying feed them
layers Mash this will provide needed
nutrients to improve egg
production good practices to protect
your chicken against disease and enemies
only allow essential staff to enter the
chicken house place a foot bath with a
disinfectant like kooper side outside
the chicken house each person working in
the house should have their own special
pair of gum boots that they wear when
entering the house remove old litter
dirty bags and rubbish away from the
house throw away old feed as they may
have molds or produce toxins keep birds
of the same age together to reduce
disease outbreaks ensure no rodents or
wild animals can enter the house
regularly clean and dry all
equipment thanks for watching if you
found this video helpful don't forget to
subscribe and hey if you subscribe today
we might just send you a virtual egg
freshly laid of course